hello everyone and welcome back to the
1972 World Chess Championship match
between Robert James Fischer and Boris
OCD beat Spassky now if you've been with
us so far you know that seven games have
already been played well seven games are
counted as being played six games have
actually been played and the result is
four to three in Fischer's favor
so again Fischer has the white pieces
and it's very interesting will Fischer
open with the usual efore or will he
once again switch to something not
standard for him and it's very
interesting as the title of the video
suggests marble or wood it refers to
before Game seven so for the previous
round
Fischer sent an official letter and it
was a really well-written letter after
the official arbiter Lothar Schmidt
where he requested that the marble chess
board be switched with the wooden one
that was used in the backstage for their
game three and Schmidt said okay I have
to have Spassky if he is okay with that
and since possibly wasn't really having
the greatest time in this match he said
yeah sure no problem he immediately said
it was okay to switch to the wooden
board as you know he really doesn't care
and if it makes Fisher happy okay why
not
so game seven was played again on the
wooden board and now again before her
game eight Fischer requests that the
board be switched to the marble board
because it is against the rules to
switch the board during the match
because if they agreed from the
beginning at the play on a certain
certain board then it is not allowed to
switch the boards once again and chief
arbitral author Schmidt had to go
through tournament regulations and the
match regulations and he found out that
there was indeed an article 18 which
says that if the players already agreed
upon a a chess board of marble then the
entire match has to be played out on a
marble chess board so it seems that
Fischer nudists and he still decided to
troll Schmitt and Spassky also but okay
for this
again eight water Schmitt could not
locate passkey before the game so the
game is still being played on a wooden
chess board and not not uh Namara bull
one so they're being said I thought it
was a very nice story but let's let's
get back to this one and one of the
reasons Fischer requested that today
switch to the wooden chess board was
because the squares on a marble chess
board appeared to be bigger the light
squares appeared to be bigger than the
dark squares so a very very nice story
but ok we are back to game eight and
Fischer opens again with c4 so not his
standard efore and if you remember in
that epic game six were Fischer first
opened with c4 Spassky went for this
solo east sex move here Spassky
immediately goes for c5 and he wants to
fight for the center Knight to c3 Knight
to c6 Knight to f3 and here as poss he
did spend some time to decide whether he
want to go east six maybe g6 but in the
end he decided to go Knight to f6 so the
four Knights variation of the English a
nice symmetrical position I will have g3
g6 push up to g2 Bishop to g7 and we
have castles castles d4 and here Spassky
could play something like these six to
go more into this a symmetrical stuff
from but rather he goes C captures on d4
we have night cap force on d4 and now
Knight captures on d4 allowing this
Queen to be centralized but it will be
on a somewhat unpleasant Square since
the bishop is also eyeing the d4 square
also very interesting and definitely
should be mentioned is the move d6 a
very nice move preparing to develop the
dark square bishop but it comes with the
idea of sacrificing one point so how
does it work well after Knight captures
pawn captures and Bishop captures black
can go Bishop to h3 attacking White's
rook and after white captures the rook
on a eight now comes Queen captures on a
eight threatening checkmate so white
would have to prevent this with f3 and
after f3
but after scheme captors yes black did
achieve some problems here for white
and the king is somewhat loose but still
it's not considered to be and enough
compensation for for the extra pawn that
white has so okay after Knight to d4
Spassky captures immediately with Knight
captures Queen captures on d4 and the
now comes d6 and okay we have Bishop to
g5 and this is already a very nice
position for Fischer as this move has
hasn't been played before in this
position after d6 moves like Queen to d3
have been played and Spassky and his
teammates of course covered many of the
games that were played in this fashion
but instead of this Queen to d3 move
Bishop to g5 was never played and what
is Fischer's idea here Fischer his idea
is that he wants to achieve some
weakening of Spassky Skiing side for
example with h6 then he wants to retreat
with the bishop and then for example
with Bishop to e3 and Queen to d2 attack
the h6 pawn Spassky doesn't go for this
instead he goes for Bishop to e6 it's
it's it's an idea he wants to keep an
eye on the d5 square you can't have any
useful discoveries with this night even
though the bishop is are in the queen so
here's Pascal first defense the d5
square now Knight to d5 is definitely an
idea opening up an attack against
Fischer's Queen from the bishop and then
go for some further exchanges here
Fischer plays Queen to f4
and this move really came as a surprise
to Spassky and it really shook him as
Spassky spent over an hour here
now it's a it's a very nice idea the
queen is no longer here so there are no
discoveries to be made
you still can't play h6 because well now
the h6 is very nicely covered so what do
you do here here after spending over an
hour
Spassky played Queen to a5 he decided he
wants to put the pressure on the Queen
side his idea is to play rook to b8 a6
b5 crack this open and have a lot of
pressure here on the Queen side and
instead of the screen - if I move or one
other possibility is actually rook to a8
rook the c8 this is an engine
but still it's it's sometimes very nice
to see how how engines make very
difficult positions seem seem quite
obvious the idea is rook the c8 now with
a double attack against the c4 pawn
after you defend it b3 now comes Knight
to g4 and now this Knight to g4 is a
very powerful move because it opens up
an attack against the c3 Knight which is
undefended but also now the Knight is
guarding the h6 square so h6 is the
threat as the bishop has nowhere to go
you would have to go to h4 so now you
cannot protect the night with rope to c1
you have to go back with the Queen Queen
here and now after Bishop captures Queen
captures now you go b5 the rook is
already on see 8a very very nice idea by
the engine so just putting it out there
but okay after Queen to f4 as possible
and Queen to a5 also a very nice move
rook 8 2 c1 Fischer now defends the c3
Knight and he prepares to further
protect the c4 pawn by playing b3 rook a
to b8 Spassky has to protect the b7 pawn
so far it wasn't really worth it for
Fischer to capture but now he actually
could capture it so now a6 b5 is
definitely an idea
first replace b3 as planned protecting
the c4 pawn and now the situation on the
clock is a Fischer spent some 30 minutes
on the clock and Spassky already spent
an hour and a half so here's Posse has
less than less than half an hour to make
27 more moves to reach time control as
this is only moved 13 in the game so
very impressive already as Pascal was
also very impressed by this especially
spelling c4 you know and he's throwing
novelties around like like he's a master
c-4 player rook F to c8 developing the
other rook and here comes Queen back to
d2 again
official now goes back from his plan of
something like Bishop to h6 and he and
brings the Queen over to help out with
the center and with the Queen side we
have a 6 Spassky simply prepares b5 and
now another move that comes as a
surprise to Spassky Fischer goes Bishop
the back to e3 seems like a very weird
move to play but it actually prevents
spassky's next move with
Spassky even realizing it here you can't
allow your looks to be next to each
other like this you have to move the rug
rook to e8 but Spassky didn't think much
of this move and he was already very
very much low on the clock
so here's Pascal played b5 he simply
continued with his plan but there is
something very wrong with this b5 move
so feel free to pause the video here and
try to find the moves Basking missed so
what what did Fischer play here I'll
give you a couple of seconds for you to
decide for those of you who who were
able to do it congratulations
it was it is not an easy move to find
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show the idea is Bishop 287
now that you see it of course it becomes
very simple because you see the light
square Bishop is slicing all the way to
8 and the rook cannot use the lights
worse and the bishop is simply
controlling all the dark squares so here
Spassky loses the exchange there's no
point in trying to save rook be captures
and c4 was played we have a bunch of
characters on b8 rook captures NBA and
now pawn captures on c4 Bishop captures
on c4 by Spassky and now rook after D 1
preparing to push the e pawn and here as
Paschal continue with something like
Queen to e5 to centralize his queen or
like Glee which suggests he should go
King to f8 but blonde during the
exchange like this as possibly didn't I
think the thing that much about this
position anymore and he really didn't
have any compensation for ok he does
have the bishop repair but you do you
didn't need more than this to show off
with your Bishop repair here is Paschal
played nice to d7 he wants to create
some threads here and also bring his
knight over into the game but this move
is yet again a blunder and spassky's
part so feel free to pause the video
once again and find the idea behind this
move I'll give you a little hint the
bishop on c4 is undefended and also the
Queen on a5 is undefended so having this
information feel free to find the move
that wins the game for white photos
who were able to do it congratulations
Spassky
Spassky missed this but you are you are
an excellent player and you are not
stressed out about everything Fischer
does and you know so on and so on so the
move is nice the d5 and now you see that
the the bishop is under attack rook
captures Bishop is a threat also the
queen is under attack
Queen captures queen is a threat and
here there's a really no good only good
movies to capture the Queen but now
White has this in-between move and I
situation Suge Knight captures on e7
width check King to f8 and only now rook
captures and e2 so the Queen's are
exchanged but so you are already up the
exchange now you have also grabbed the
pawn it doesn't really matter if you
move the bishop the knight will safely
get out of out of harm's way so after
work the d2 Spassky played King captures
enter now comes rook captures in c4 so
now not only not only is a Fisher of the
exchange but also as poss he doesn't
have his extra pawn anymore so rook to
be one with check okay we have Bishop to
f1 and now nice the c5 spa's people
still try to create some problems for
Fisher King to g2 we have a five now
Spassky does have some chances if he is
somehow able to get rid of this a to
pawn and perhaps do something with his
own past a pawn we have E for Bishop to
a1 as poss he wants to get his Bishop
into the game before pushing f6 at the
prevent Fischer's e5 so f4 we have f6 s
planned and now rook to e2 King to e6
now comes rook eat the c2 doubling up on
the C file look to be Bishop to b1 to b2
preventing roof to c1 and the now comes
in Bishop to e2 we have h5 in by Spassky
rook to d2
Bishop to e3 and now f5 this comes with
check G captors on i-5 for pawn captures
on f5 and King to e5 you cannot capture
and c4 on f5 because the rook captures
on c5 a very a very nasty idea
and now after we capture Bishop to d3
check the king
and also picks up the rockin be one so
this would be very unfortunate for
Spassky but everything after those two
blunders is a very unfortunate for
Spassky King too if I was played now
comes Roxy 2d for King captures on f5
and now rook to d5 with check King Mo's
now comes rook captures and d6 would
check King to e7 and after rook to c6
here as Pascal decided that there was no
point in in continuing this game as he
is simply down too much and he decided
to resign the game he's going to lose
the h5 pawn and then it's simply push
push to win so yeah now this is game 8
of the 1972 World Chess Championship
match between Robert James Fischer and
Boris facilities Posse I do hope you
enjoyed it as Pascal definitely didn't
so it's hard to say and it's very
interesting although when one day
Spassky in his seconds when they talk
about the games in the match and when
they recall everything they weren't all
that bothered by the these silly
requests Fischer had I mean as possibly
couldn't care less if he played on a
marble board or on a wooden board he
just wanted to play chess but something
something was off something just wasn't
right so yeah yeah Fischer is now in the
lead 5 to 3 and it will be now very hard
for Spassky to catch up but well you
know we'll check up on what happens with
game 9 very soon and continue this very
nice story I would like to thank Brian
Carey Carmen mares Lauren's button
runoff petit and Danny McCullough for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot - really appreciate it as usual you
can check - on my previous videos here
think all for watching and I'll see you
soon
continuing the Bobby Fischer series but
also I will check up on some of your
suggestions if there were any and I
believe their work so thank you all and
I'll see you soon